hi everyone it's Jerry I have a nice
game to share with you from 2018 on the
white end Hannibal playing against Leela
chess
zero okay let's see how Leela handles
the black pieces handles the grunfeld
defense I think this is an excellent
game it highlights uh Pawn play very
well okay let's get these standard moves
in out of the grunfeld defense no
castles here for black instead puts an
emphasis
on Queen deployment to this typical
Square in
A5 what is she doing from A5 what
reasons can you come up with feel free
to pause the
video okay those of you that took the
time to think about this pause the video
you were being graded here are a few
notes we can make about Queen A5 we
pinning a pawn attacking and
unprotected Pawn threatening to break up
White Center currently
white is not in a position to recapture
and maintain this Pawn
Duo if you came up with those reasons or
something very close to it I don't know
you've earned a
B+ now I'm sure none of you right now
are thinking what do I got to do around
here to get an
A well there's another note we can make
about Queen A5 and that's going to be
revealed soon enough in this
game I'm just presenting this position
to you in this way uh to maybe have this
game be a bit more memorable for
you okay we continue Queen D2 breaks the
pin on the C Pawn White's now in a
position to recapture with the pawn only
now do we have
castles White NOW secures
C3
so there's a new pawn move available to
White D5 is
available if you try D5 5 too soon C3 is
going to collapse this is
possible if black plays Bishop G4 here
D5 is an excellent reply in this game
though it's Knight D7 supporting an E5
Advance the reply Bishop D3 white
continues to develop I want to touch on
a couple different Pawn structures a
couple different pawn moves instead of
Bishop D3 what are we doing as black if
E5 well rook d8 and and then this is a
very uncomfortable position for white
there's a pin on the dile there's a
threat to take on E5 a couple
times also what are we doing if
D5 Knight F6 this line right here is
considered uh equal is right around the
corner suggests E6 put pressure on the
most invasive Pawn in this game though
it is simply Bishop D3 E5 met with D5
white now has a connected past Pawn we
continue with F5 there is a threat to
squash the bishop it is short on squares
white continues with Queen C2 opens a
square for the
bishop instead of Queen C2 if C4 we can
exchange queens and then put pressure on
e4 a point that would be difficult if
not impossible to
maintain
okay in this game Queen C2 it is F4
still Bishop D2 another Pop Quiz pop
quiz number
two what move would you play here feel
free to pause the
video okay pop quiz number one and two
are
related this is the other reason behind
Queen
A5 B5 is
available this is on the Queen's side
after all a majority it's set into
motion now if you don't play B5 here
another move I think many players might
think about in this position is H6
preparing to expand on the king side if
you play let's say H6 there is C4 the
queen moves somewhere and this guy
really is is kind of on the
backward side here he would much rather
be up to the B4 Square this is a half
open file the B Pawn if he's on B7 he's
somewhat backward this is Black's
opportunity at this moment right here to
get the B Pawn
rolling B5 it is C4 B4 right around the
corner is this idea of A4 taking
advantage of the pin along the
diagonal timing is not quite right for
A3 here though if A3 we can take with
the queen and there is no Rook A1
winning the queen because the Rook is
not defended but after castles this is
now an
idea black recognizes this and says I'm
done mission accomplished on the queen
side with the queen and now her
attention is on the king side where she
supports
G5 she's not staying developed black has
the eye on kingside expansion now this
square is now opened up for a pawn A3
A5 two things are happening with
A5 secure the B Pawn and a rook lift is
possible all of a sudden this idea shows
up all
right we continue with Bishop E2 the
computer for many moves in this game
this is the first point where it
suggests a takes B recapture and then
make use of these connected Rooks these
guys Black's Rooks are not connected it
wants to take on B4 and then get to the
a file never quite happens though Bishop
E2 in this game in comes
G5 H3
H5 okay what are we doing about G4 white
says I want a square for my knight if
you're going to give me a kick I want to
have some
security so in Comes The Rook
lift h H4 G4 Knight G5 this guy is
shortlived what is the idea behind The
Rook lift you can see it asack Queen
Rook sacrificed for a kingside minor
they're soon going to be a problem on
White's King
side so this
center it's all locked but look at the
space the play here is happening on the
wings and who who is superior on the
wings look at all these invasive black
pawns all right Bishop D3 is the
followup and from here we have Rook
takes Knight if the Knight hops in here
we're still swiping the Knight this is
even worse this would be even worse for
white cuz after this recapture this is
no longer under control by a pawn why is
that a big deal well this Knight gets to
go home and soon it will be a best piece
on D4 there's really no stopping this
maneuver all right in this game Bishop
D3 in Comes The Exchange sacrifice black
is simply going to be there first on the
king side white goes after this weak
link but look at this pressure on G3
right around the corner idea is to maybe
take twice get to
H2 white has an eye on defending ideas
like that Queen H5 Queen takes a
B3 I like this B3 move it
buys uh black sometime or really slows
White's progress down on the queen side
if white is allowed to take here can
quickly see one of White's pawns become
pasted on the C file B3 it is takes some
time to track this guy down now Rook
B2 and now maneuvering the Knight trying
to get to this G5 square and from that
point
couple different jumps very
scary Bishop
C3 this is now another idea there's an
intersection square or uh the G2 Square
the queen would like to get there from
here Queen takes
C5 a lot of passed Pawns in this
position all these pawns are pass three
White Pass pawns but let's see how black
organizes the pieces ready for Knight G5
Knight H3 the bishop to defends
G5 Bishop F6 some pressure on this Rook
prevents Knight G5 has a
responsibility and now these next few
moves black is reorganizing the pieces
Shifting the bishop the rook and soon
the king to the seventh
rank okay Rook takes B Rook F7 Bishop
back to D2 Knight G5 there goes the
Knight you really cannot allow Knight
here with check there's ideas to next
swipe the pawn take
here completely uh collapsing position
for white so Bishop takes Knight it is
Bishop takes Bishop this guy here is now
an unopposed dark Square Bishop there is
a dream diagonal for that piece this is
it this is really the golden square
there's one support point for the bishop
and it's going to try to get there from
here we have a
check white pushes there's a threat now
on the pawn easily defended the bishop
goes to D2 so I wondered about a
different move here instead of this
advance I thought well what if white
tries to interfere with this
maneuver so for instance what if the
Rook goes
here that's not going to help because
black can take on G3 and then there's F2
so this Rook needs to stay here to fend
off this F2 idea so then I wondered well
what if this Rook comes back here to
watch over this that wouldn't work
either because black can take on G3 and
then step back with the queen and now
there's two ideas one get to
D2 with the
bishop trying to get to D4
and get to Simply E3 with the fork and
there's no stopping both Bishop moves in
this position it's going to get to one
of these two next okay very strong
battery formed here white is very weak
on the dark squares that was the better
Bishop that was given up for the Knight
after all all right in this game D6
Bishop
D2 Rook d8 black is simply there first
C3 it's bad enough the check but now a
fork completely gone here for
white gives back the
exchange the followup Queen H3 Queen
takes G and what a convenient move here
Queen may be trying to get here no
problem King G6 defends that and there's
also Rook
H7 Rook H2 Rook H7 still don't take the
Rook it's going to be mate what's tried
Queen G1 at this stage black can
exchange
queens and follow up with a check and
you don't have to take the Rook here in
fact if you take the Rook it's
considered a draw nope push the pawn and
after Rook takes Rook don't even take
back continue to push because next up
you're promoting with check and forcing
resignation this is as far as it goes
game
over if the game continued it's a mate
two King H3 we have check and
Checkmate what did you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care
bye